it's a little bit disconcerting at first
because you're not exactly sure what's
going on when the wheelbarrow started
floating up into space and you just
thought the only way this could possibly
be happening is if it's actually not
floating up into space but it's actually
sinking down into the ocean with that
moment you've realized they're not
walking on the top of the ice they're
walking underneath it oh I get it
the finns have filmed everything upside
down
but just how have they managed to
achieve such a piece of mind-bending
genius what they have done is created
just the right amount for buoyancy to
simulate gravity so if we're standing on
earth gravity is pulling us down and the
earth is pushing up against us but what
they're doing is they're using buoyancy
to push up against the ice and the ice
is pushing down on them when they walk
it looks like they're walking normally
with the effect of gravity and in fact
they're walking upside down with the
effect of buoyancy